the aftermath of a huge New Year's Eve
airstrike on a school building used by
the Russian army it is about 10
kilometers inside russian-held territory
and Ukraine's Donetsk region a strike so
large that even Russia had to admit it
took place
a military spokesperson saying that 63
Russian servicemen were killed by four
u.s-made hymar's Rockets Ukraine has
claimed responsibility for hitting the
building and said it is clarifying the
death toll earlier Tuesday Kiev
suggested as many as 400 Russian
soldiers were killed there has to be
some skepticism but I think the fact
that the Russians admitted that 63 died
this is an idea of the scope of the loss
prominent pro-russian military bloggers
claimed that the building where the
troops had gathered on Saturday night
was also used as a storage for
ammunition
[Music]
the death of the Russian troops happened
as Russian State TV broadcast a
patriotic New Year's special
featuring smiling military leaders in
the audience one Ukrainian MP told
Global News the airstrike indicates
extremely poor judgment from Russia's
military to place so many soldiers in
one place it shows that Russia is you
know Russian army is like a big
dinosaurs massive body and Tiny heads
and very tiny brains inside olexe
goncharenko spoke from a train on route
to Kiev Ukraine's Capital that continues
to deal with nightly airstrikes
targeting its energy infrastructure Kiev
authorities claim they shot down 39
drones overnight Redmond Shannon Global
News London